hello and welcome to maths imply if you
fall sick very often or frequently
suffer from flu sore throat and skin
infections it's possible your body needs
vitamins to boost the immune system the
best way to increase your vitamin intake
is by having a healthy and balanced diet
but sometimes our bodies need an extra
boost most of the time the immune system
does its job by keeping us healthy
however if the system sometimes fails to
defend us it can result in illness
infection or diseases this is where the
body needs reinforcements in the form of
vitamins and other immune boosting
nutrients in this video we will look at
the top five important vitamins that you
need to include in your diet to boost
your immune system and fight off
infections
our first vitamin that is essential to
boost the immune system is the vitamin A
vitamin-a takes part in the production
of white blood cells in the bone marrow
and helps the body to fight infections
from various types of bacteria viruses
and other pathogens this is key when a
virus is present in the body white blood
cells will fight the virus and even
eradicated quickly in case of an
infection if your white cells are off
the chances of infection will increase
greatly vitamin A can be found in
vegetables such as carrots spinach
broccoli and cabbage also it's found in
dairy products like milk butter and even
fruits like melons apricots and mangoes
vitamin B strengthens the immune system
vitamin B is not just a single vitamin
rather a complex of eight vitamins that
have numerous roles in our immune system
for example folate or vitamin b9
promotes the production and function of
white blood cells
vitamin b12 or cobalamin is also
essential for the production of immune
cells vitamin b6 or pyridoxine plays a
critical role in energy levels and
immunity vitamin B is key to the overall
function of the body because it
regulates the absorption of a lot of
other components as well when either
vitamin b12 or b9 is low there's usually
a decrease in a number of circulating
antibodies as well thus the body will be
exposed to a large number of infections
and the capability of quickly recovering
from infections will diminish foods like
avocados strawberry and banana are very
rich in vitamin B while other foods like
dairy products such as yogurt or milk
also have it in sufficient quantities to
add variety eat vegetables like
asparagus as well as meat and fish in
order to have enough vitamin B in your
diet
perhaps vitamin C is one vitamin you are
most familiar with because it has been
used since ages to boost immunity and
decrease the duration of colds and flu
vitamin C also called the ascorbic acid
is an essential micronutrients for
humans and one of the most widely
consumed dietary supplements in the
world
vitamin C increases the production of
interferons a protein which helps the
immune cells to fight viral infections
many research groups have suggested the
importance of vitamin C indeed and it is
still considered one of the best
vitamins to promote a strong immune
system it boosts our immunity in many
other ways which we have discussed in
detail in our next video which will be
about the role of vitamin C in
strengthening our immunity check the
links in the description bar below for
more details
vitamin C can be found in citrus fruits
like oranges and lemons as well as other
fruits like blackberries guava Kiwi and
strawberries nevertheless between C can
also be found in huge quantities in
other vegetables like red bell peppers
try mixing up your sources to eat
different foods in every meal
our next immune system boosting vitamin
is the vitamin E vitamin E helps the
immune system because of its antioxidant
properties it helps fight free radicals
and helps ourselves to regenerate and
work seamlessly
it can be found in walnuts almonds
peanuts and it is also found in
sunflower seeds spinach and broccoli the
best oils that have this vitamin are the
sunflower oil wheat germ oil and soybean
oil
vitamin K is an essential fire soluble
vitamin involved in heart and bone
health however it is also among the best
vitamins for the immune system health
vitamin K acts as a cofactor for many
plasma proteins and strengthens our
innate immunity vitamin K that we
absorbed from our diet is related to
intestinal bacteria therefore the blood
vitamin K levels greatly depend upon our
digestive health
this video features five of the best
vitamins for immune system health
including vitamin A vitamin B vitamin C
vitamin E and vitamin K we also explain
how each vitamin benefits the immune
system as well as which foods are rich
in these vitamins a vitamin rich diet
will be heavy in fruits vegetables and
other whole foods when you do supplement
with vitamins it is best to choose a
high-quality product made from real food
sources and free from fillers or toxins
I recommend Nature's Way multivitamin
supplements which contains all the
vitamins that we just discussed and also
has loads of other micronutrients which
gives boost to the five essential
aspects of a healthy immunity which is
cellular immunity circulatory immunity
digestive immunity respiratory immunity
as well as systemic immunity links are
in the description bar below if you're
one of those who is not into taking
vitamin pills check out this video about
the top 10 foods that you can include in
your diet to boost your immunity thank
you so much and see you in the next
video bye-bye take care and stay safe
thank you so much for watching